hey what's up guys my name is a Charo
and welcome to a video that will show
you guys how to get Cherno chat which is
the application that we made in the
network chat programming series how to
get Cherno chat up and running on a
linux server so first of all let's let
let's export it right so what we've got
here is eclipse and this is of course
the entire setup the exact same setup
that we used to actually make make the
application here so let's go ahead and
export us first of all just so we didn't
get anywhere any errors let's go up into
here and next to the debug button you'll
see a drop-down arrow make sure you go
to debug configurations here and then
essentially in arguments just remove the
arguments okay because sometimes with
Eclipse it can give you a bit of a bit
of an error being like you can't use
program arguments outside of this
because you'll have to enter them
yourself and blow a lot so just to avoid
any kind of confusion clear that hit
apply over here and and you'll be set
okay so let's explore this thing so you
can either go file export or you can go
right click on this and choose export
over here okay right click on the
project and there's there's a few
options here so you're probably thinking
you know what let's um let lets let's
export it as a runnable jar file because
it we want it to be a runnable Java file
if you do that right because we have to
export both the client and the server as
different applications right because
obviously what we've done here in this
project has essentially created two
different applications one of them is
the server for cherish out of one of
them is the client for chat so two
applications if you choose a runnable
jar file and hit next you can see it
doesn't actually give you an option to
select what kind of classes you want so
what you'll end up exporting is class
files for all the server stuff okay and
if you're the client you don't hate that
kind of stuff so in other words we want
to kind of reduce the file size not that
it's gonna be big anyway it's probably
gonna be less than 50 kilobytes but um
we definitely don't want to be exporting
stuff we don't need
so select jar file over here and hit
next now the cool thing with this is it
actually tells you select the resources
you want to export so if we go down here
in sauce we can choose to basically just
uncheck the server ok and then what
we'll get over here in this packages you
can say is client client window login
and online users ok you can see that the
splitting this up into two packages
allows us to select only the stuff we
need so you can see that if we if we are
if we actually just um if we pick this
this channel sure thing without the dot
server on the end we have client client
window login and online users this is
all we need to run the client side if we
click on the server one you can see that
server server client server main
uniquely identified that's all we need
to run the server side so basically just
like that one don't select the server
okay and you'll see a bunch of other
code here that's all right explore
destination just hit browse on that and
on the desktop I'm gonna make a I'm
gonna make a file here called um sure no
chat client since this is the client I
hit save
okay so now I've got an export
destination okay and then over here you
go to export generated class files and
resource you want to have that checked
everything else leave that unchecked
everything will be fine compress the
contents everything's good hit next now
over here it's gonna ask you a few
things for handling problems just don't
worry about that okay but they'll
probably be warnings because I think
we've got a few warnings such as unused
imports that's all right you can't clean
that up if you want so this this job
actually options should be fine to sit
next now manifest specification this is
where it gets a bit more real so um the
only thing you have to do here right
don't worry about the manifest file
don't worry about anything all you
really have to do is select the class of
the application entry point okay you
have to select the main class so the
main class of course is the class that
has the main method so the the the
public static void main string args that
method okay which for us is either in
the server main if we're the server or
in the login if what the client since
we're extracting the client right now
let's go ahead let's just go ahead and
hit browse and then actually comes up
here okay login because this is it um it
automatically finds the main method this
is the only main method that we have
within this package of course we've got
another one in the server package but
we've run this like to be client to
package for export so hit OK and that
that's it okay hit finish and what it
should do is is explore stuff you might
get a few warnings there just compiled
warnings don't worry about that
everything is cool okay hit OK
you are done that is the client now we
have to do the same thing for the server
ok so again we'll just go ahead and
we'll just go ahead and hit file export
it's like Java file again I want to run
through this a bit faster over here
basically in under source let's uncheck
the client so it doesn't say da client
but the one that doesn't have the dolt
server appended to the end it means it's
a client version you can see this one
has no server so we'll select everything
in servers you can see we just did here
and we'll leave the client on check here
next oh hang on let's rename the Java
file to be a Trinitron server ok let's
hit next on that we'll leave this as it
is and then the main clause we'll hit
browse and you can see here we have so
many automatically detected hit OK on
that and hit finish and you should be
ready to go so now let's see if that
even worked ok I'm just gonna go ahead
and open a Finder window go to my
desktop here and then you can see that
I've got a bunch of stuff I've actually
got two other ones because that's what I
exported for the video yesterday as well
as some other things so I'm just gonna
go ahead and delete that so it doesn't
cause any confusion so here we have here
we have two files we've got b7 client if
we just double click on the client that
should at least run for us and we should
see how that works so you can see it
does bring up this login thing so
basically it's working yeah so let's go
ahead and close that right so now we've
got the two files let's go ahead and
upload them to the server and I'll just
switch over I'll stop this video here
and I'll continue it with the server
view in hand alright so here we are in
the server view I'm connected via SSH
using a utility called putty which is
basically just an SSH client so I've SSH
into my server and here you see the
command line for my server so this is
Linux this is running Debian 6 okay that
is the Linux distribution that's not too
important ok this will run under
anything the first thing you have to
make sure is that you actually have Java
installed onto your server ok so the
quick way to check that is just by
typing in Java then space then - version
ok that will tell you what version
you've got you can see have about 1.7
dot 0 underscore 45 I think that's the
latest version of it at the time of me
recording this so the point is we are at
the latest version of Java we actually
have Java ok that's the important thing
Cherno chat is actually written in java
6 so even 1.6 will work but um we've got
1% which is even better let's just clear
that clear that screen so what we want
to do now is is actually get the chat
thing so I've already made a folder I've
added director on my cervical Turner
chat ok
that's great so now we want to actually
get it right we need to get that jar
file that we just exported from our Mac
or from Windows if using that we need to
get that into you all onto the server
right numerous ways of doing that right
the way that I've done it I've already
placed it into this directory I've done
it by simply um by simply using FTP or
actually SFTP which is the SSH version
of FTP to get some to get the file onto
it so I've just literally uploaded it
from my from my for my desktop onto the
server and sorry my Mac is making a lot
of noise here it is really hot today by
the way the top today is 44 degrees
Celsius which is like a hundred and five
or so degrees Fahrenheit not sure but
it's freaking hot today anyway point is
um that you need to get the file to your
service on here right I've done that via
FTP essentially SFTP okay
now there are other ways of getting this
if you guys have the file upload it
somewhere I don't have the exported jar
file upload it anyway you guys are gonna
have to export it for yourselves but of
course you could use something like W
get for example if you have a tunnel web
server there's a lot of different ways
to get the file but point is you need to
volunteer server once you've got the
file I'm just gonna go ahead and hit LS
you can see that I've got one file in
this directory
Cherno chat server jar okay that is the
jar that we just exported now to run
this it's gonna be really simple okay
all you have to do is hit Java
- jar then the name which is Chan our
chat server I'll just hit tab and it
will recognize that so Java - jar
China chat server dot jar and then one
command-line argument which is the port
at which you want to start the server on
okay so for example we've been doing all
this time 8 1 9 - and then hit enter ok
and you can see it says over here server
start our import a 1 9 - and this is
everything right we can go ahead and we
can go slash help and it will tell us
all of our available commands we can go
ahead and do slash clients will tell us
who's online no one's online right now
but essentially what we get here in fact
let me just don't right now I'm just
gonna go ahead and I was actually gonna
get you guys to all join this having
like a little event and see how many
people would go into this and see how
many people - server
could handle in fact I will you know
what let's do that Oh actually no let's
not it that's not because I actually
have such a do I forgot but um at one
point I think I might do that okay so
anyway the point is I'm just opening the
client now on my Mac I'm gonna try and
connect to that and we're gonna see what
happens okay so and I'm gonna have to
blow out my EFI address but I'll call it
yawn space Mac that'll be these name IP
address for this as the general comp
since it is my web server and then we'll
login and then over here is all good it
didn't have my IP address
it says Y on Mac connected so I've
connected now and I can say something
like hey and you can see that it gets
all that data if I go ahead and do slash
clients you guys will see that that Here
I am with that IP address that I'm about
to blow out but some that is essentially
everything that you need to know again
and that works as it does okay which is
wonderful so that's how it works and if
you haven't even enable raw mode you can
see everything that's happening so you
can see the pings that happen here and
all of that good stuff so anyway that is
that's pretty much how you run it on a
Linux server particularly particularly
debian in this in this in this example
although of course the Linux
distributions are all pretty much the
same so you'll be you'll be fine
anyway that's gonna wrap up this video I
hope you guys did enjoy it if you did
please hit the like button
I'll put up another video probably
because I want again I want you guys to
UM to get into this and and I don't see
if we can have some fun chatting to it
to each other on this on this server ok
on this some will fly ownership ok so
yes so follow me on Twitter if you don't
want to miss that and I'll see you guys
later
good bye alright so one thing that I
actually forgot to mention was how to
actually shut down the server so of
course let's first of all disable roll
mode online command there we go Ramar
adolphus just because of the other stuff
we got online command anyway so Rama is
now off great what I'm gonna do here is
is shut down the server so of course we
can just type in slash quit ok just get
you guys in know that so if we type in
slash quit hit enter it will say all
disconnect else of course and you can
see that the web back into control here
and we can clear the screen and we're
back in control of our server ok so that
is how you stop a server see you guys
next time goodbye
you